good morning John a couple of days ago
President Trump shared a former map of
Dorian the Hurricanes projected path
first hats off to the people at the NWS
who do hurricane projections because the
three-day forecast which is the most
important for evacuations has been spot
on for this entire hurricane and that
has saved lives
second the Sharpie mark see the
president also said a few days ago that
Alabama was like in the crosshairs of
Dorian and this is something that would
be a totally normal flub like people
sometimes when they're talking say the
wrong thing then probably president
Trump maybe somebody else drew a little
sharpie line on the map to like include
a little slice of Alabama and then it
was like a front-page story in a lot of
places Sharpie gape trended on Twitter
and people were suggesting maybe Donald
Trump should be prosecuted for sharing
false weatherdata that last one no it
wasn't a predictive map it wasn't shared
as a predictive map it was saying here's
what we thought might have happened and
we got lucky and that thing didn't
happen but it is also very clearly weird
think that newsworthy and important are
synonymous they're not it's important
that the Golden Gate Bridge didn't fall
down today but it is not newsworthy
because it's normal the first condition
to whether something is newsworthy is
whether it's abnormal is a sharpie gate
important maybe as like an illustration
of the degradation of the shared
foundation of truth and the most
ham-fisted way imaginable mostly from
what I saw it was used as like a window
into the inner workings of the
president's mind and that's always gonna
be guessing like we know that's all
guessing but here's the thing I know
it's easy to say that President Trump is
bad at everything but one thing he
really gets is attention and I think
that pretty much everybody like even his
supporters get that he prefers the
spectacle of this whole thing more than
the process of actually governor and so
like two or three times a week we have
some fresh spectacle that he is
responsible for like it's at this point
pretty clearly not a bug it's a feature
this isn't to say that it's good for him
like personally or for his reelection
chances there's like 30 York from Herman
patty rappers in this trash and testing
to the fact that just because you like
something doesn't mean it's good for you
it's also not to say that spectacles are
unimportant part of the process of
governing is actually getting stuff done
he's creating a shared story that people
can believe in it's fighting for a
particular store and theatrics are a
good way to tell a story and people at
the center of attention are the ones who
are most able to shape a narrative and
to some people these weird theatrics are
exciting somebody draws a line on a map
and suddenly everybody's exploding it
fits into this narrative of like the
press and liberals being ultra critical
of Donald Trump by being abnormal Trump
gets to always be in the spotlight and
because he's in the spotlight he gets to
craft a narrative like he's the producer
of a reality TV show but the wild thing
to me is the only story he seems to want
to tell with this great power he has is
one about himself one where he's the
ultimate and only Savior one where
everyone has to be loyal to him or else
and one where he's always right even
when like it's clear he made a mistake
ultimately I think this is why we're so
exhausted not just because like we
remember a time back before we had to be
paying attention to this and there was
some fresh new spectacle coming out of
the Oval Office every two freakin days
but because the spectacle is ultimately
always about the same thing
it's pompous and it's selfish it's
egotistical and it's smug he has a
tremendous skill for controlling and
crafting narrative but instead of using
that for any kind of shared vision it's
always only about himself and that's
exhausting not because it's always in
your face but because of how dangerous
it actually is I don't know the way
through here I'm just describing a
situation if we don't treat abnormal
things like their news then they just
become normal but when the strategy
becomes be abnormal for the sake of
attention the only thing you can do is
realize it and then like vote it out
every time John I'll see you on Tuesday